hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
early on in being in time in the
introduction section six Heidegger is
going to introduce a new key term
historicity and he's connected this up
with temper ality we shouldn't merely
view this as sort of a new mode of
temporality like first you've got
temporalities and then he add history
into the mix by you know taking away or
adding something to it
historicity is always there as something
that is characteristic something that is
essential to design even when we don't
realize it as Heidegger is going to
point out so Heidegger tells us that
temporality is the condition of the
possibility of historicity as a temporal
mode of being of design itself that's a
nice phrase there and he goes on and he
says as a determination historicity is
prior to any sort of history whether
it's world history whether it's the
history of a particular people or
chronicling or anything like that this
is an existential structure of design
itself as human being which means that
this extends back into prehistory of
human beings as well so he says what is
historicity historicity means the
Constitution of the of being of the
occurrence of design as such that's a
little abstract isn't it what what what
should we unpack that the constitution
of being of the occurrence of design
design human being emerges as human
being through having this this dimension
of historicity so he goes on and he says
this is a nice phrase in its factual
being design always is as and what it
already was
a little bit later he's going to frame
this in a little bit more succinct terms
design is its past we exist in the
presence right but we exist as beings
that have a past even if we you know
look at these kind of science-fiction a
or detective novel things of people
who've got complete amnesia they don't
really have complete amnesia which is a
lack of memory of what occurred in the
past because they know how do you say a
spoon or what a spoon is or how to speak
English or any of these sorts of things
and that can only happen by having some
sort of a past involved doesn't mean
that all there is is the past of course
or that the being of design is only its
past so he says whether explicitly or
not it is its past it is its own past
not only in such a way that its past as
it were a beautiful metaphor pushes
itself along behind it and that it
possesses what has passed as a property
that is still objectively present and at
times has an effect on it sort of like
you know the fact that you have certain
determinate characteristics of yourself
that have been charted and you know for
example right now we're we're creating
something in the present that's going to
be part of a past in in creating this
this video he says design is its past in
the manner of its being which roughly
expressed on each occasion occurs out of
its future so we're constantly oriented
towards the future but we're constantly
also bringing realize that are not a
past along with us now you might say
okay how does that get us history or
historicity maybe I just have my own
individual past do you have your own
individual past well it doesn't really
work like that it wouldn't be a coherent
past Heidegger is not really going into
this in detail here but it's worth
dwelling on it wouldn't really be a
coherent past if I was isolated by
myself as the only member or rememberer
of that
past so he tells us that because of this
design grows into what he calls a
customary interpretation of itself and
grows up in that interpretation now he's
not spelling this out but typically that
interpretation is is happening through
interaction with an entire world of
others and perhaps even my imagination
or memories of those others within my
own being so what does this give us
he says design understands itself within
this interpretation at first and within
a certain range constantly so he calls
us an elemental historicity of design he
tells us returning to the point of
designs historicity precedes history
itself that this can be easily concealed
from us as a matter of fact many people
don't realize this about themselves it
could be that in the modern era in
certain respects were privileged with
respect to this but there's also
possibilities of concealment as well so
he says design can discover preserve and
explicitly pursue something like a
tradition this is where it becomes more
conscious says the discovery of
tradition and the disclosure of what it
transmits because if you think about the
nature of tradition tradition is not
just simply a monolithic thing out there
that you have to bow down to and allow
to imprint itself upon you tradition is
literally the handing over of one thing
or multiple things from one person to
another and so who is doing the handing
what is being handed all of these are
things that can become questions for us
and tradition is itself you might say
reinterpret 'iv so he goes on and he
says that the discipline of history is
possible only as a kind of being
belonging to incurring design we are the
only animals
that engage in history and it doesn't
necessarily have to mean writing history
books
it can mean asking wait a second I
thought that Uncle Fred was married to
this person and you know had had three
kids with with this person was that all
a lie right that's historical in a sense
it's bringing a past into the present in
such a way that it it matters in some
way now he says if historicity this
dimension of historicity
remains concealed from design and so
long as it does so this is a very
important point the possibility of
historical inquiry and discovery of
history is denied and he says so if the
history as discipline you know something
that you can study something that you
can read is lacking there's no evidence
against the historicity of design
historicity is there it's just not being
understood as such and the more that we
attend to this fundamental category of
historicity not even category structure
dimension the better we're going to be
at not just doing but also receiving
history here's where we get to a really
interesting point so we brought up
tradition right and there's a
possibility of having a kind of
tradition which would be a positive
appropriation of the past allow it's
full possession of the most proper
possibilities of inquiry that's not how
tradition often functions however and
this is why we can have that conception
of you know like tradition and fiddler
on the roof you know tradition I have to
follow it you know I can't think for
myself I I have to just you know follow
in this this thing that's been sketched
out for me and never deviates that's one
conception of tradition but it's a
degenerate understanding of tradition
now Heidegger here is going to talk
about a tradition of what later we will
call Western metaphysics here he's going
to call it ontology and this is a
tradition that is in many respects
really great it's it's what we fill our
history of philosophy books with
and in fact rely upon in many of our
philosophy classes without even
realizing it and you know spread
throughout all sorts of medium over and
over again generation after generation
without realizing that it has become
something restrictive something stifling
rather than something that opens reality
up to us so he tells us design not only
has an inclination to get entangled in
the world in which it is and to
interpret itself in terms of that world
he says at the same time design is
entangled in a tradition which it more
or less explicitly grasps and that
tradition is coming down from us from
you know some original Wellsprings he
says we wind up being barred in our
access to these original wild Springs
and we forget where all of these
interpretations of being come from you
might at this one also wonder if you
know anything about Martin Heidegger why
if he thinks that all of these people
are in a certain respect blocking our
access to the originally insights that
the Greek thinkers prior to Plato had
about the nature of being why would he
bother talking about them and analyzing
their ideas at such great length in
being in time why would he give lecture
after lecture on each of these modes of
thinking because each of them does also
contribute something something
originally something interesting
something that reveals being more to us
but the problem is is that they also
conceal in the process and they can
become as he'll talk about it a little
bit later here we go sclerotic right
think about when things become hard and
things become congealed they no longer
have any sort of flexibility so he goes
on and he says at the outset we showed
that the question of the meaning of the
was not only unresolved but not only
inadequately formulated but that it had
actually been forgotten why because of
this entire tradition he says Greek
ontology and its history which would
include Plato and Aristotle through many
twists and turns still define the
conceptual character of philosophy today
and they are he says proof of the fact
that da sight understands itself in
general terms of the world so the
ontology that comes down to us from the
Greeks is going to get taken up
eventually by you know the Christian
thinkers who introduced the notion of
creation ex nihilo and a number of other
things that's going to morph into
scholasticism as Heidegger says it
becomes a fixed body of doctrine in the
Middle Ages and he also tells us though
this is a good point
within the limits of its dogmatic
adoption of the fundamental Greek
conceptions of being this systematics
the Christian systematics contains a
great deal of unpretentious work which
does make advances so at each point
there is advances being made but this
tradition is continuing through and it's
winding up with different shapes
different different interpretations then
we move from the Scholastic model into
Descartes and eventually through Kant
and Hegel now what is getting
misinterpreted in this entire course if
you read on through section 6 you'll
find him talking about several different
things that are that are you might say
missing in the picture he talks about
Plato right and what what plato was was
viewing in his work then Aristotle he
says Aristotle not not understanding
dialectic by placing it on a more
radical foundation and transcending it
then we get you know the Christian
thinkers then we get Descartes and he
talks about Descartes here as having an
ontological position
that leaves out something very
fundamental that Aristotle had actually
talked about and the Christian thinkers
had thought about time temporality and
thereby also historicity Hegel at the
very end of this is bringing historicity
back in but Hegel is a inheritor of this
tradition and despite his great
brilliance which Heidegger certainly
acknowledges at many points he's he's
giving us a way of approaching these
things that is ultimately not going to
be productive it's not going to get us
back to the question of being and so
what is Heidegger tell us that we need
to do if we want to recover the
dimension of historicity in such a way
that we can actually do proper history
he says we have to D structure the
history of ontology how do we do that by
looking at these key ideas these key
ways in which design understands itself
and showing as Heidegger says the
provenance the fact that they didn't
come down as ideas like manna from
heaven
they didn't just emerge you know like
Athena out of the you know split head of
Zeus you know out of the the genius of
the thinker so that we can't you know
ask about it we can get back as
Heidegger attempts to do in as many
lectures and discussions to thinking
through what was it that the thinker was
trying to make sense of and why did they
go the way that they did this is what is
later going to be called quite commonly
a genealogical approach but it's also
called a deconstructive approach as well
and so Heidegger is advocating that we
carry this out and that we do it in
particular by focusing on time
temporality and historicity
you